foreign
is in Los Angeles hi Cameron welcome to
the Ramsay show
hi thanks for taking my call today sure
what's up
hey so
um I need a little bit of help and
guidance from you
um kind of where to start I'm a little
overwhelmed with a lot of my finances I
started yesterday by figuring out some
debts and I've I've realized that I'm
really behind on a lot of my basic
utilities and um and taxes and I'm
trying to get started on the baby steps
but I just feel so overwhelmed because
I'm behind in so many things
okay so I kind of need to know kind of
how to start on all this it's a scary
place isn't it brother
hell yeah how old are you
33 and what's your income
um I would say on average right now
about 30 000 ish a year what do you do
uh we're getting entertainment industry
so I do a lot of stuff for musical
theater so anything from costuming to
wigs and all that kind of stuff okay all
right about how much debt do you think
you have
um well when I totaled it up yesterday
I'm gonna just probably uh rounding it
to about ten thousand dollars
well you know what I know it's scary
right now but I just want to say good
job getting on board
like we're really happy that you're
calling today
thank you
yeah so here's the thing number one
we're going to send you a copy of the
book The Total Money Makeover
all right and that's what uh close to
nine million people now I've got that
book and I've used it and I'm not
selling your book I'm giving you one so
you don't you just have to read it
that's all you got to do now
um so here's what I would do in your
situation before you start the baby
steps you need to be current
with your utilities and current with
your bill okay so the first goal to get
current is make a list of what each bill
like the electric bill what's it take to
be current on the electric bill what's
it take to be current on the water bill
what's it take to be current on the dot
dot dot fill it in okay and that's just
to be current
follow me and then your goal when you do
out your written budget is you're going
to budget out in any money you can
squeeze out of your budget you're going
to work down that list smallest to
largest
okay so like if it takes 20 bucks to get
a bill current whether and that's your
little one boom that one's Done Right
easy right it takes 50 bucks to get
another one boom that one's done that's
easy right and so the more of them you
get in the current side the the more
your stress is going to drop because
right now your stress level is like up
in your throat you're chewing on your
stomach
yeah you know what I'm saying I remember
that I used to remember that like I get
a little sweat in the palm of my hand a
little bit above my eyebrows and um and
your heart rate goes up when you make
those lists of stuff and you just like
freaked out like you've jumped off a
building and you're just falling or
something you know what I'm talking
about
yeah yeah that's how you feel right
oh yeah yeah yes sir so more of that is
going to go away the more of this you
get and control the second thing is just
by making the list your stress level is
going to go down because now we've
Quantified the size of the Dragon
that must die this Dragon must die and
you are a night young man you're going
to kill the dragon
and it must die it may take a bunch of
cuts it may take a bunch of swings of
the sword uh you may get really tired
and you're definitely gonna get some
blood on you but the dragon is gonna die
you're gonna kill it because you're just
the guy that's why you called us we're
dragging we're night trainers we're
going to train you to kill the dragon
all right you can do this yeah so
the second part of this equation is
there's two sides of the equation income
and outgo
thirty thousand dollars a year in Los
Angeles California as an income sucks
you're starving to death
you have got to do some stuff to add to
your income and I don't care if it's
something that's not pretty or not fun
if it what you need right now is some
Monday
ten thousand dollars would change your
life
can't say that about a lot of people
yeah so the good the bad news is you got
ten thousand dollars worth of debt the
good news is it's only ten thousand
dollars worth in other words if we
increase your income with a good strong
part-time job it's fifteen thousand a
year you're going to be debt free 100 in
less than a year if you just live on
what you make at your regular job
yeah so part-time job is in your future
I don't know if you're delivering Uber
Eats or if you're delivering pizzas or
if you're walking dogs or you're cutting
grass I don't care what it is but you
need to go do something for Monday good
money
don't take something cheap not minimum
wage I want you to make some money
and and just be I don't want you to do
anything illegal and I don't want you to
do anything immoral that puts your
ethics at risk anything like that but
short of that go get you some money
because ten thousand bucks have changed
your life that's pretty cool right now
that you can do that so my prediction is
you're going to be debt free in a year
yeah I would like to it's you know I I
find it hard as well in my situation
because
um I make my income varies month to
month because the type of work that I do
yeah it varies from sucks to not sucks
is bad
[Laughter]
you have got to get some more income
coming in and really your long-term
career has got to get better would you
agree
uh yeah you don't want to be making
thirty thousand when you're 50.
right so what are you gonna do what's
going to move the needle you got you
keep doing what you've been doing you're
going to keep getting what you've been
getting agreed
yes sir yeah so we've got it we got to
work on the career side short term long
term and we've got to work on organizing
the money and the expenses in a budget
in the short term and you can walk right
straight through this hold on we'll have
Austin pick up we'll give you a copy of
Total Money Makeover and get you going
well and the fear you're feeling right
now it's super uncomfortable but I want
you to turn that fear into the what we
call here gazelle intensity where you're
like a gazelle running away from a
cheetah and the good news is with ten
thousand dollars this can be gone
quickly it's scary right now and it
feels overwhelming because you're
looking at all these bills and you're
behind and there's debt but you can
tackle this quickly especially if you
take that fear and turn it into focus
and use it to propel you forward into
knocking this out yeah I think you're
right if you're standing in the middle
of the interstate and an 18-wheeler is
coming you feel discomfort yeah and
that's that's a good discomfort get out
of the freaking row it's time for a
change where your stamming is going to
get you killed and that's what you're
saying here where the way I've been
doing things has got to change on the
income side and on the outgo side it has
to change otherwise next year you're
going to be sitting exactly here with
the exact same stresses different names
and the exact same build problems
different names yep and so the good news
is you can just decide today Ready set
go this is America even in California
it's still America you can still go do
this and you can get out of that and you
can change this whole thing and you need
to look long term at your career and
what you're going to do but short term
right now I just want you to go get some
Monday and clean this mess up